born in Canada to a Cuban father you  would think Rafael Edward Cruz has quite  the claim to be the outsider in this  race the education at Princeton and  Harvard the spellers a Supreme Court  Clark and under visor to george w bush  perhaps tell a different story and  sitting up there in Congress as a  senator from Texas also makes for an  awkward truth for a man apparently  intent on sticking it to the Washington  elite we will not give up on freedom for  the Constitution and we will not give up  on the United States the Ted Cruz's the  darling of the conservative movement the  support of the Tea Party and sarah palin  swept him to victory in 2012 in what was  regarded as the biggest upset of the  year he ticks all the boxes  anti-abortion pro-gun aunty the IRS and  pro-death penalty he's also a man of  deep religious picnic it is a champion  debater at college that is said to love  an argument for the ocean there's a  tendency to win